- all: OH!
- WHOO HOO HOO!
- EDUARDO, MAN,
YOU ARE SO LOCO, MAN!
- WOW.
- WE NEED A CRAZY VATO
LIKE YOU IN OUR GANG.
- SI.
- WITH THIS BANDANA,
I WELCOME YOU TO THE GANG.
- YO.
HOLD UP.
- OH...KAY.
- WHAT'S GOING ON?
- HEY.
CARLITO.
UH, I WAS JUST WELCOMING EDUARDO
INTO THE GANG.
- WHY?
WHO HE?
WHAT HE DID?
- HE'S--HE'S CRAZY, MAN.
WE--WE WERE THINKING
THAT THE GANG NEEDS A CRAZY GUY.
- YEAH, YEAH, MAN.
THIS GUY IS LOCO.
SHOW HIM, EDUARDO.
LOCO!
- THAT'S MUY LOCO.
- LOCO.
HUH?
- NO, NO.
I'M THE LOCO ONE IN THIS GANG.
- WHAT?
OKAY, OKAY.
- CHECK THIS OUT.
QUACK, QUACK, QUACK.
QUACK-QUACK.
I'M A DUCK.
I'M A CRAZY DUCK.
- NO--CARLITO.
- QUACK.
- CARLITO, IT'S NOT THAT KIND OF
LOCO, OKAY?
THAT'S MORE LIKE, YOU KNOW,
ZAINY.
OR--OR GOOFY.
- YEAH.
- IT'S THE WRONG KIND OF LOCO.
- YOU WANT TO SEE LOCO?
- CARLITO.
YOU'RE NOT CRAZY.
YOU'RE LIKE, UH, THE QUIET ONE.
- I'M NOT QUIET.
I NEVER BE CAUGHT
BEING QUIET.
IN FACT, I'M ALWAYS LOUD.
CHECK IT.
AHH.
- OKAY.
OKAY.
THAT WAS WEIRD.
THAT WAS--WERE YOU YELLING?
- I'LL SHOW YOU LOCO RIGHT HERE.
RIGHT NOW IN BROAD DAYLIGHT, YO.
- CARLITO, NO.
- OH, MY GOD.
- CARLITO, PULL UP YOUR PANTS,
HOMES.
- I GOT TILIKUM ON MY UNDERWEAR.
THAT'S THE BLACK FISH.
I'M NAKED,
AND I DON'T EVEN CARE.
- CARLITO, YOU GOTTA
PULL 'EM UP, OKAY?
THERE'S, LIKE, CHILDREN
IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD, OKAY?
- OKAY.
BUT CHECK THIS OUT.
I GOT NINE PUNCH CARDS
FROM FROYO UNIVERSE,
EACH WITH A ONE STAMP IN IT.
EVERY TIME I GET A FROYO,
I GET A NEW CARD.
- CARLITO, THAT'S JUST BEING
CAVALIER WITH YOUR FINANCES
INSTEAD OF COLLECTING
YOUR FREE DESSERT.
I MEAN, THAT'S NOT LOCO.
THAT'S JUST, LIKE,
FINANCIALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
- I MIGHT NOT BE LOCO,
BUT YOU KNOW WHO IS LOCO?
MY FRIEND MR. BASURA-HEAD.
- HE'S DUMPING THE GARBAGE.
- HI, I'M THE MOST LOCO PERSON
IN HERE.
- CARLITO.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
- QUE?
- CARLITO.
OKAY.
CARLITO...YOU DON'T HAVE
TO DO THIS, OKAY?
IT'S NOT NECESSARY.
YOU'RE NOT THE LOCO ONE.
- CHECK THIS OUT.
DER.
I FEEL--YEAH, I'M CRAZY.
I'M THE LOCO ONE.
- CARLITO, PLEASE DON'T DO
IT AGAIN.
- OHH!
- CARLITO, STOP.
- I'M IN TOO DEEP.
- THIS IS LIKE WATCHING THE
BRITISH VERSION O THE OFFICE.
LIKE, IT'S FUNNY, BUT AWKWARD
AND SAD AT THE SAME TIME.
- YES.
- OH!
- WELL, I THINK I JUST PROVED
THIS BOTTLE IS UNBREAKABLE.
[glass shattering]
- CARLITO.
YOU'RE EMBARRASSING YOURSELF.
- LOOK AT THIS.
- NO.
NO, NO, NO, CARLITO.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO WITH THAT?
- I DON'T KNOW.
I'M TOO CRAZY.
OH!
- CARLITO,
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT, MAN?
THAT WAS LOCO,
BUT NOT IN A ENTERTAINING WAY.
- OKAY.
- CARLITO, PUT DOWN THE GUN,
HOMES.
- OH, DON'T YOU FEAR.
- PUT THE GUN DOWN.
- THE CRAZY, CRAZY ONE IS HERE.
- CARLIT--STOP!
- PUT IT DOWN.
- OH, MY STAPLE HAND.
- PUT THE GUN DOWN.
- DON'T DO THAT.
- I SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT.
- CARLITO, STOP TWIRLING IT.
- LOCO, LOCO, LOCO.
WHERE SHE STOPS?
NOBODY KNOW--CO-OH.
- FUCK!
CARLITO, YOU JUST
SHOT EDUARDO IN THE HEAD!
- NOW I'M THE MOST LOCO
IN THE GANG?
- YES, CARLITO,
BY PROCESS OF ELIMINATION,
YOU'RE THE MOST LOCO PERSON
IN THE GANG.
- YES.
- all: OH!
- LOCO!
- HE CAUGHT THE BULLET.
ORALE!
HE CAUGHT THE BULLET
IN HIS TEETH!
- LOCO!
- THAT'S THE MOST LOCO-EST THING
I EVER SEEN!
- all: NO, NO!
[gun shot]